well here's a crazy idea how about we
ask Sheldon what he thinks of all this
no ahead he's not gonna want to go
this is his home were his family she
doesn't can you come in here for a
minute
yes every seat won't talk to you all
right
so today we found out about a school in
Dallas for really smart kids when can I
start
hold on Dallas is far away so you'd have
to live with another family do they have
a dog uh we don't know well can you make
some calls
I guess but wouldn't you miss your mom
and dad oh yes I suppose I will so when
are you calling about the dog you know
him so well
[Music]
what are you talking about they're so
quiet
are they on medication mm-hmm they're
just smart like you I've been going to
school in a zoo not sure about these
uniforms kind of frou-frou Sheldon I've
been looking at your transcripts and I
must say I'm very impressed thank you
what's your doctorate in non commutative
algebraic topology I like her it's gonna
be weird around here I thought Sheldon
don't you mean less weird that's not
nice
one trying for nice you sure you're not
jealous kid your little brother's moving
up in the world
hi I got plans of my own dude tail soon
as I graduate high school I'm gonna be a
professional male model that is
hilarious
what I'm good-looking know that you
think you'll graduate high school the
model thing was funny too I must tell
you in all the years I've been here I
have never seen such glowing letters of
recommendation from a student's teachers
well that's real nice to hear listen to
this putting aside his superior
intellect Sheldon is a delight to have
in the class
he's fun-loving easy to get along with
and always ready to help another student
that doesn't sound like me at all sure
it does sweetie dr. Douglas no please
call me flora flora I have to ask about
the living arrangements that's our main
concern well I think I can assure you
about that my husband and I have been
hosting a student for the last several
years who recently graduated and is now
at Princeton so we have a guest room
available in our home that's very
generous of you is your husband working
to school also no he's retired he's an
astrophysicist for NASA please tell me
you don't have a dog no we're both
allergic I'm tingling
[Music]